nice
we are live
round
two
with dr jay sanguinetti
thanks for coming here
so good to see you again
yeah
yeah you too and so much has transpired
for us both since we first talked so
really looking forward to this
conversation and how it unfolds
me too i've been looking towards towards
this for a while so very good to see you
a lot has happened since 2019
it's so interesting how much the
synthesis of science and spirituality is
becoming
more mainstreamed
um
yep i i think the pandemic has played a
big part in that you know it was already
going on before uh with things like
michael pollan's book on uh
psychedelics and their potential healing
powers
um but you know i think the pandemic has
really given people the chance to
take a step back
uh
see what's important and what's not
important and sort of get rid of
a lot of the fluff in their life and
start focusing on sort of inner
well-being inner practice for some
people spiritual practice
or contemplative practices like
meditation and yoga
and you know i think it's helped center
us in a lot of ways it's of course hurt
a lot of people
deeply as well
but you know i think that
sort of comes with the territory of
going through something like this
yeah it's becoming more popular for
people to be talking about the turn
inward
and that's fascinating
i
love that i love that and
and that's almost where the seat of
unity is
it's it's all around us
in every inhale
but it's
most
in a sense
anchored in its truth
when we turn inward and recognize
that
indescribable
that
we are that is
infinity
expressing it and
when we and especially when we drop the
mind to the heart and then that that's
sort of where
yeah where this unity and this oneness
really begins emanating also from that
from that turn
inward and so it's so nice
yeah to see it becoming more mainstream
and
and also for science to be giving
so much more
excitement and funding and allocation of
resources to this
and
we were talking about this before we
started but the eprc and having dan
ingram on the show as well and you guys
being a part of that
and
also around everything that's transpired
with sema lab which we'll talk about
more as well
and the nuances around the findings
around
how
neurostimulation neuromodulation can
positively affect people's mindfulness
their feelings of coherence and oneness
and
and just brain and behavior also
and
this is gonna this is gonna be so so
pumping to unpack this
cool yeah
lots to talk about cool
let's let's do this jay so let's maybe
take this from the
um
from where like from where we kind of
left off
and where
you guys are at now the last two years
have been
you know intensely filled with
bringing forth these realizations of the
synthesis of science spirituality to
mainstream and showing this empirically
with
data so
let's let's unpack that so take us
through that journey and then we'll pull
up visuals and stuff as we go as needed
sure
i think the last time we spoke i was
had just left the bay area where
i really was pivoting my entire research
career towards what's what's called
contemplative neuroscience in the field
so
uh scientists i think maybe rightly so
are a little bit afraid of the term
spiritual and spirituality
um partly because it's ill-defined um
you know what's the spirit uh how do you
measure that in an mri scanner
so
right which you know has its own
problems and we can get into that but
you know i think what you're talking
about is
inner experience trans transforming
people can have transformation of their
inner experience their inner life their
inner world
through lots of things having a child
falling in love uh somebody near you and
dear to you dying and passing away um
psychedelic intervention
lots lots of ways sometimes it just
randomly happens to people
so you know there's lots of ways to have
that inner experience transform
and there are practices that have been
cultivated
throughout you know 2500 years or so
to intentionally
cultivate inner well-being inner
happiness and inner self-understanding
uh with in buddhism for example the
ultimate goal of enlightenment or
reaching nirvana
um and so what's really exciting right
now and sort of where my life has
pivoted is that science is starting to
look at these practices and ask what the
heck is going on
and many scientists are actually
starting to do the practices and going
whoa
my inner world is changing i want to
study that i want to know what is that
and ultimately a scientist we want to
help
we want to use science to help reduce
suffering and help the world
and so many of us are looking at these
practices and saying
is it possible to strip away the stuff
that we can't study like the religious
social stuff the religious stuff is it
possible to strip that away keep the
practice and
and find something meaningful for people
or do you need some of the religious
stuff that's also a possible
you know finding that we'll come to as
well
um but that's really where we are you're
sort of merging these practices that
come from religion and spiritual
practices
with science
and asking is this a possible paradigm
for the future now many of us like
myself and like you who do these
practices like mindfulness uh yoga other
things
uh we have a deep intuition that this
will work
that you can blend the stuff with
science create a new paradigm and make
it useful for not just weirdos like me
and you
but for everybody you know
i've got family members down in
mississippi who want to use this i've
got friends in in boston and baltimore
i've
you know my collaborator shenzhen is
working in china you know can we make
paradigms that are useful across the
board independent of your background and
your inner experience and your past
experience and your socioeconomic status
and all of that
can we help people transform their inner
lives so that we don't have to go
through a pandemic to ask the question
what's meaningful for me
you know can we just use these tools in
the first place
so you know that's kind of where we are
we're at the very early stages of
blending um what are called the wisdom
traditions with western science
and trying to see like what falls out
and you know truthfully
i don't know what falls out of it i
think the new science is going to be
quite different than even what we think
today
but we're at the very beginning of
trying to make this a real grounded you
know empirical scientific
paradigm and it's super exciting
okay
so
what seems to be reoccurringly
critical in this process
is
the simultaneous
of the wisdom traditions with the
western science
and yet also a mainstreamification
of the benefits the applied benefits
globally
so
let's
let's play with with um
okay let's play with like the
mainstreaming
and the
in the um
and the very
sort of simple
boiled down essence of what we're doing
with blending the wisdom traditions and
uh in western science
because
it really boils down to simple things
like increased happiness and less
suffering
and more openness
more equanimity
uh
these types of things this is sort of
what the the core potentially is
yeah i'd add self-understanding and
uh
service to others is probably the
deepest one um so yeah there's lots of
components that go into it
yep and you might want to also you know
it's fun to play with the the benefits
and the positive but
we can also bring up all the uh pitfalls
and and uh
the walls that can emerge with this so
there's also the commodification the the
mick mindfulness that's also happening
the sort of
is there too much for stripping away uh
can you strip away the practices to the
point where they're
helping with the tension and you can
shoot a basketball better but they're
not getting at these things that we just
outlined
so you know that's the other end and the
nice thing about science is we can
address those questions
uh and if we're being careful and you
know upfront with our science we should
be
you know creating paradigms where we can
catch that as well
otherwise we'll just be looking over at
the benefits and not realizing that they
may be causing some damage at the same
time
yeah very important point
um very very important point yeah and a
lot of it is really it boils down to
extracting out the most signal um the
most essence
and then um distilling that to
mainstream most relatably
and yeah not getting lost in the
commodification of things um or in all
of the noise um as well so that's that's
great
so
okay so let's take um
let's take a
like a classical um
um portion of of neuroscientific
research so
we've we've been hearing a lot about how
excessive rumination in a default mode
network seems to be a big culprit of
anxiety
self-referential
thoughts about the past or about the
future
and that
taking people out of peace out of
happiness out of now presence
um
out of
unity and into separation even
so if i'm not feeling peace and
happiness what am i doing i'm trying to
extract peace and happiness
so are we are we talking um when we
talked about a month ago um we were
chatting about things like um
a decrease in the
overactive default mode network
and a um and then there being sort of a
blossoming of that you were calling it
internal
transformations that unfold for people
and that these internal transformations
these shifts you could say
from suffering to well-being or
prosperity toward oneness away from
separation that these sort of things
come from a neuroscientific
consciousness oriented
shift
yeah that's a great question so
uh let's define default mode network for
people who don't uh know about it so
it's a region in the brain that's kind
of midline that showed up in fmri
studies when people were doing
no task so between tasks and the scanner
sometimes will tell people just sit
there
it's you know 400 to a thousand dollars
an hour to do an mri so we usually just
record everything even if they're not
doing a task
and what we found and by we i mean all
my colleagues not me
what we found is
that for most people cross culture you
tend to see this midline area activate
and that seems to be what people go into
when they're not doing anything
it's kind of your default state it's
going to be different for each person
because we all kind of default to
different sort of defaults but it's
what's happening when you're driving
your car and you kind of mind wonder
and yeah there you go
most classes
yeah you pick up your phone you go into
facebook whatever your default sort of
you know i don't have anything to do let
me take five minutes
most people have the experience of
driving their car and uh you look up and
you're like oh crap how did i get here
right so your body was driving and
you're up in your mind and your default
sort of worrying about the pandemic and
whatever politics or whatever you got
going on
so that's the default states and it
evolved for a purpose it's there to sort
of help us
sort of relax a little bit not be so
engaged if we're constantly engaged with
thinking uh like problem solving it take
a lot of energy so it's kind of a a very
relaxed thinking state
typically people think about their own
stuff so one marker on the default mode
network is it's about you
yeah so yeah someone said autopilot so
it's autopilot but it's auto self pilot
[Laughter]
um because it's really like you start
worrying you start thinking you start
thinking about dinner
you know you start thinking about all
these different things but it's almost
thinking about you and that's a really
salient marker of the default mode
network
so interesting content
auto self pilot yeah interesting yeah
cool me and rick henry just came up with
that
yeah
yeah that's publishing paper
that's somebody in the chat so um yeah
yeah we pulled up this comment yeah
yeah
like this like we pulled it there we go
oh i love that yeah
you'll see you'll see more of those
throughout yeah
we also had this earlier the super
excited for dr j's work oh thank you
nice name
yeah i know
cool
all right
yeah so the dmn the default mode network
is
it's really there to maintain
self-processing you can think of it that
way um
we're still learning about it
some process
so maintenance
process
oh interesting okay cool cool that's
that's the way i think about it there's
a lot of debate in the literature about
this different people think different
things but
what we do know is that
well if you think about the self
from the point of view of like trying to
create it which is i think what the
brain is doing in the body it's a big
process it's a lot of activation and
processing and computation you know the
self is not an easy thing to make
and then once it's made it needs to be
maintained if someone hurts your
feelings you need to think about it
right like why did they say why did alan
say that thing to me i gotta go think
about that does that mean i'm stupid or
is alan stupid i gotta you know i gotta
think about that for a little while
and eventually i have to get myself to a
point where i feel okay you know i need
a baseline level of okayness
but i also need to be able to take
feedback from you think about myself do
i need to
work on my tone a little bit because
alan said i don't sound good on the
microphone you know yeah i'm getting all
this input and i got to take that in i
got to do something with it and i got to
do do the self stuff
so that's the default mode network it's
super important we never want to make it
go away
but in things like depression
things like anxiety
things like a pandemic or you're
watching negative news
then what can happen in that state is it
tends to go negative
and negative can go overdrive
and so depression for example is like
those people just ruminate they just
negative negative negative every moment
they get to think to themselves it's
like the world is burning
there's no point
why is alan looking at me you know they
just like
just goes like that and that and that
and that then perpetuates negative mood
and it perpetuates the whole inner sort
of
uh what's that nine-inch nail song where
he's talking about like being in the the
whole right like you're just going
further and further into that black hole
and that becomes a problem because at a
certain point you just can't get out
now if you look at
the other end so that would be default
mode on hyperdrive and i can see that in
the mri if i take a depressed person and
i put them in the mri you can actually
see too much activation
now
here's what's interesting if you take a
massive dose of psilocybin
magic mushrooms
mdma lsd any of the major
psychedelics
the first thing you see is that that
default mode network goes
[Music]
way down
and it seems there's a couple really
early studies but it seems like the more
you turn the default mode network down
the more ego death you experience
yes
um and the term in the literature is
actually
dyed um
oh i'm forgetting the term but it's
something like direct ego death it
spells died so ego died
so in the ego death experience actually
predicts clinical outcomes so if you
have ptsd patients for example and they
take some 5mu dmt for and they you know
you measure the stuff in the mri scanner
those people are good for weeks
sometimes after one session
if you can get that default network to
really shut down and the report of the
self
having a literal ego death you know like
oh my god it was scary my ego died but
now
i see how i can heal myself you know
it's kind of what people report
now those are the two ends of the
spectrum with the default mode network
most people are right in the middle
when you start meditating
guess what happens that dmn starts going
off but only when you meditate
so and you're in the scanner and you're
meditating even if i put you in i would
see relative to your baseline that your
default mode network is just turning off
just a little bit not not like a
psychedelic but you know you're starting
to get that to decrease
and my friend judd brewer published a
bunch of beautiful studies where he was
showing this in meditators
and so
it now becomes a target for intervention
so if i have someone with depression
and i have a device that can target
specifically the default mode network
can i help reduce their rumination just
a little bit
so they get they get a little
psychological freedom
right and then if i can get some
psychological freedom can i do some
therapy in that state or you know get
them to interact with their loved ones
or work or whatever they need to do
so that the system can kind of bootstrap
out of that crappy state and into a new
state
so yeah that's the fascination with the
default mode network it's it's a pretty
cool thing we still don't know too much
about it at this point but
yeah it's it's becoming an interesting
target
this is so fascinating so we could
potentially see that
evolutionarily
that
as over the last couple of millions of
years that
the
the creature the vehicle of the creature
became
advanced enough
neurophysiologically to
be to have a um
a self-referential
model
and then to basically perpetuate um said
self-referential model based on
biological fitness
um
and
then um
then
basically every time that it would not
be doing a task
like uh if it's not hunting or cooking
or making textiles or whatever moving
etc trading all that type of stuff then
it's basically in its relaxed state
between actions
um that it's usually ruminating
on
what happened in my self-referential
model in terms of the past what can i
learn from that what can i avoid like
what what pains can i avoid in the
future
um and then there's like the future
like uh
it's kind of like a monte carlo tree
search in computer science so it's like
running all these little simulations of
future possibilities and trajectories
self-referentially oh if j does this
activity then j will get this said you
know this fruit up in the tree uh and so
you know there's this that there's that
activity so it's almost like the
self-referential model
um
that relax time
uh turned into
like avoiding pain seeking pleasure
um
and then that further perpetuated the
self-referential model
and it also further perpetuates like uh
like unhappiness with with now
um with
the
there's not much gratitude for
uh what it what is now like what about
now like is this not
absolutely beautiful like how
two seemingly individuated
humans
in a universe are having a conversation
across computer technology on a rock
orbiting a star like
uh you know like you know you get to a
way of being able to describe the now so
profoundly that you realize how
ridiculous it sounds like for you to
take five minutes
and then like have to jump on this
device and have to incessantly scroll
and you realize that during the five
minutes
if you sort of work on this default mode
network
you can sort of over time
quiet down that excessive stimulation
and
then now you're beginning to get into
what some of the mystics have also been
figuring out is well what happens when
you have these these uh complete uh
cessations of
of
of pain
of pleasure
so of craving and aversion um
but also of this self-referential model
itself
um so that's something that we could
probably table and put a little bit
further but that plays directly into
what you were saying around entheogens
and ego death and um
and then this feelings of oh my gosh
universal consciousness or unbounded
energy
emptiness
that all of these things come up and the
realization of we're all god this is all
one intelligence at play with itself
comes up and then science is like how do
we compute this how do we compute
right
[Music]
yeah yeah so so we'll let's um
let's maybe put the um the
the self-referential model completely
sort of colloidal a little bit further
but it's fascinating evolutionarily how
it looks like that's exactly what kind
of like upticked over time is that
process and how its potential that would
you say that with everything that you're
looking at and what sem is looking at
and what not that sort of the default
mode network and then also the neural
stimulation for
the decreased overactivity would you say
that that's one of the top findings that
you're figuring out
uh that's one of the main focuses of the
lab
you know we
we sort of do projects we can only do so
many a semester based on funding and
things like that so we're sort of going
at the heart of what we think will
in our lab actually facilitate
mindfulness practice so that's what
we're doing in my lab which is called
sema lab
i co-direct that with shenzhen young
who's a very well-known mindfulness
teacher in the united states
and in semilab we're trying to find
we're trying to understand how does the
brain change with um right now
mindfulness practice but we're
interested in other practices
and then once we understand that can we
safely target that with things like
neurostimulation or feedback like
neurofeedback using eeg can we target
those systems while people are
meditating to
give you something that helps you learn
the mindfulness skills
the mindfulness practice
so you know we don't want things that
work as dramatically as psychedelics
because we can get into that i think
although they work really well
that is a temporary state and that
doesn't lead to lifelong change actually
and i want to be very clear because
people are asking here i think
psychedelic interventions are great
great medicines
but it's not just getting the person to
the state and and even to the ego death
i don't think that that will be enough
to save humanity from climate change or
something as some people are claiming
um you need to have a way to integrate
that information integrate that insight
and integrate the skill
of being calm having equanimity having a
focused attention
you know getting out of the default
state when you need to to to give your
talk on a stage or whatever you're doing
you need all of these things need to be
integrated back into the nervous system
and the body
and so really what we're focused on is
the first part how do you understand the
brain when it changes with meditation
maybe even psychedelics
can you target those systems with
neurotechnology to help people meditate
with more ease
and then if that happens does that
actually help them integrate these
practices into their life
so that they're happier
they're having better relationships with
their family they're having more
fulfillment from walking on a trail in
nature you know all the things that
really we're trying to get to
does all the stuff in the lab translate
into life and that's the hardest part to
me actually is
even with psychedelics you know most of
us probably on this chat here have been
to you know
uh concerts and places where people have
done a lot of psychedelics and those
people aren't often the model human
you know they're beautiful people with
lots of insight but you know you
probably wouldn't want those people
running society
so there's got to be some
other trick uh to help us integrate
these things in a way that are pragmatic
and practical um
for having a society where we all have
to interact with each other
um and so that's really that integration
part that's the the last step of the lab
um and as you're talking about with
identity um you know that's the core
because really what we're talking about
is
the the sense of self and
it's suffering you know deeply for all
of us
if we're being truthful
and some people are suffering with
things like depression and chronic pain
but you know the rest of us are
suffering with a lot of other things
and that self is attached it identifies
with that which is totally
understandable and useful
but that stuff can go haywire and it can
lead us down a path where ultimately
at the end of our lives we are on our
death beds and we go oh my god
why was i so attached to my porsche 911
in my giant house and my job like
it's my family and
nature and oh my god climate change is
happening and it's i'm dying and it's 20
50. why didn't i do anything about that
you know it takes like getting to death
before people get there
and that's because of the way that the
self is built and what it thinks is
important and what it's attached to and
and what what is threatening which is a
whole big piece of like all this threat
i got to take care of my family so i got
to go work you know
70 hours a week and whatever uh
realizing that your family could be okay
with half the income and you don't need
all this crap and
you know so you know you're really
getting at that system of self-identity
and attachment
and trying to understand how does it
work
and
how can you modulate that in a safe way
through meditation practice psychedelics
you know sports all kinds of things will
modulate it but how do you modulate it
in a safe way so you still go to work
you're just not so attached to a 80 hour
work week you realize you know you can
get the same amount of work done
with 40 hours and you can have more
equanimity oh and by the way you can
have more fulfillment at work
you know you can get to all that so you
can kind of detach and get back out and
do what's important and so i think these
questions about identity and self and
like how those systems work
that's the crucial stuff that we're
really working on
that's great because
as
buddha pointed to with dependent
origination
that
the first link in all of this
is
from
source
what is the identity
what is is it knowledge or is it
ignorance and knowledge means
knowledge means that you know anata or
no self
and then
versus ignorance of
means that you are
attached to the sense of i me mine
and then then the cycle of samsara kicks
in which is craving and aversion and
indifferences and that right there is
the you could even say that that's like
the core of
how this dimension of creation even
works
this entire extent of creation appears
to play in a way like you have all this
differentiation of all of these costumes
where you have this apparent
j unit in this apparent atlas allen unit
and that then these units
uh have the same underlying essence that
everything is a boundless energy i play
with itself but then fascinatingly
enough on the surface when it comes into
shape name form costume there is the
appearance of it being different which
then further perpetuates the sense of i
being here and that sense of i being
there and then that being separate from
each other and needing to extract from
one another so the oneness
becomes veiled
so you could even say that the entire
creation plays off of that initial link
in everything or
in as said independent origination that
everything is interpenetrating itself as
vibration as energy even as you know
quantum mechanics eludes that everything
is absolutely non-local it's absolutely
entangled
you can't come to an understanding of
how a zero-point energy ends up
creating of the quantum field theory
quantum electrodynamics that then
produce said
cells that are recursive that make these
30 trillion unit vehicles
it's absolutely mind-boggling and um
and so then that right there
before anything else is if we start with
that sense of self that sense of
identity and deconstruct the [ __ ] out of
it first and foremost um that that can
then be one of the biggest
like rocket ships for us in our
awakening but then there's the simple
[ __ ] like you just said which is very
important which is bro you're on a walk
you're literally on a walk and like you
love like walks come on man you're not
supposed to be
thinking about oh my god all this stuff
in the past or oh my god all the stuff
in the future
like we all know that that's not the
right way to take a walk
like you're supposed to take a walk and
completely relax and enjoy the beauty of
the sun enjoy the beauty of the trees
and of the birds and the bees and enjoy
the person that you're with be grateful
for your life be grateful for the air
that you're breathing be grateful for
the water and the food and the roof over
your head and if this is again a very
simple style of shift
um into that type of a mentality as
you're
like also buddha called it a
non-meditation
that your your entire day's life is not
uh
a meditative it's it's not supposed to
be something that you go and sit on a
cushion but rather it's an every moment
of your life is the very wakeful
state um
so yeah so that's really important
resonant um and it also makes a lot of
sense given what you said with um
with neurofeedback because i feel like
one of the big things that we're
shifting to moving forward is that
um
and perhaps this is something that i
don't know if you guys have have been
looking into this as well or are
potentially even doing it or know of
people doing it but it's really exciting
um
is is uh haptics for neurofeedback
um so that you're getting um
a tactical
signal
about when
um
you're
about when you're getting you're getting
ai biometric readouts that are then
signaling to you when you're going into
a state of perpetuating your sense of
self and
uh craving an aversion
versus when you're in a state that's uh
a lot more coherent and so you haptic
feedback along that um that process
so yeah what you know so what are the
types of um existing um
yeah ways of i know
i love the like fractally nature of of
the
play the tennis that's happening
because there's so many ways for you to
for you to play with that um so take
yeah if there was a thread that you
liked in the last bit um you can take
from that and also just take from the um
that especially the leveraging ai and
biometrics and neurofeedback on
assisting people on less offering more
happiness
sure i was laughing too at the chat i
love it i i taught during the pandemic i
had a class with 300 students on zoom
and i left the chat open and yeah it
gets fun pretty quickly uh so keep your
chat we'll speak to them i did want to
say one thing in the chat um i you know
i made a comment about people uh doing
psychedelics not running the country um
i should clarify
what i mean by that is any
i i like i said i think psychedelics are
definitely healing especially used in
the right context but i think that
timothy leary's insight that the
sentence setting is crucial to the
experience that you have and actually
the insights that you have
i would take it further though and also
say what you do after so the larger
context of
what's your intention why are you doing
these in the first place
and you know i've been accused of this
in my own research which is that we have
this society that's really looking for
the pill the red pill or the blue pill
right our favorite movie the matrix is
all about this you just take the pill
and you wake up
that might not be how the nervous system
works
it might be so there's traditions in
buddhism for example that have argued
something along that
once you understand the true nature of
yourself and reality
it shifts everything shifts that's a
possibility and a hypothesis in science
that i'm very interested in
it could also be the case though that
the nervous system mine is 37 i'll be 38
uh this next month
uh you know there's 38 years of neural
memory
not just in my brain but in my spine and
all the way in every cell
in my body
um the cells have memory the dna
probably you know rna all this stuff in
here all the machinery
is shaped by experience
and so you know one thing that i'm very
careful about and even in my own
thinking
is to look for just the special pill or
the special device that i can just put
on
and it somehow hits the right button
and then you're done
you're enlightened and you see the true
nature of reality and everything and i
think that we have built into our
psychologies probably through evolution
this
bypass
there's something built into us that
if you take the right mushrooms and
humans have been taking mushrooms for a
long time it seems like
you can have an experience that feels
like the truth
and you become certain of that truth and
then you start telling everyone about
that truth and then as you talk about it
the sense of self reifies the ego sort
of reifies makes it more real than it
was when you experienced it
and there's there are these sort of
psychological biasing mechanisms that
we've studied um in the field for other
reasons but i've really sort of been
thinking about a paper of
uh
sort of
psychological biasing mechanisms as
applied to inner shifts you know inner
experience
and you know buddhism for example has
been talking about spiritual bypass and
you know the sort of pitfalls that you
can fall in in buddhism
the sort of
traps that you can get stuck in there's
lots of different traps
shenzhen my collaborator actually writes
about this in his book
as like four levels as your
consciousness sort of gets cleaned up
and at the third level there's this sort
of
magic stuff that happens
lots of weird psychological powers and
things that happen and there's whole
sort of sex of buddhism based on these
powers
you can get stuck and what shinzon says
is you can actually get stuck lateral
so you get in these this power realm
your you got kriyas and you got these
energies popping out of your mind and
you're seeing the world in a completely
perceptually different way
and you start practicing you start going
lateral so you're gaining more power in
this realm and you think you're getting
towards enlightenment if that's your
goal but you're actually getting you're
going
horizontal with enlightenment you're not
going down towards it you're actually
going this way and things are happening
and you can talk about them and you're
very sure that you're getting closer to
enlightenment
but you're actually in a trap
and i'm super fascinated by these traps
because i think there might be a sort of
a protection mechanism built into us
to fall into these traps so that we
don't get lost in the void
or nothingness right because
as an embodied human being i i can't
hang out in the void all day i need to
feed the metabolism systems in my body
i got to get some outer energy in even
if it's not actually separate in some
quantum physics way
right and so you know the the
the psychology for some random reasons
may have figured out a way to get us
trapped
into
that lateral dimension so that we can
keep functioning in the world even if
it's sort of taking us further away from
the truth and we're getting stuck in
this what's what's now being termed a
spiritual bypass we're sort of getting
stuck in this experience and the ego is
getting looped and talking about it and
telling everyone about it but the
psychological cleanup or the development
or the growth that actually could be
taking place is getting bypassed and
you're just telling everyone how
enlightened you are
and so i'm equally as worried about that
as you know creating tech to get people
there
and as a scientist all of this is
fascinating the fact that this seems to
happen to people across the spectrum
so anyway sorry i wanted to i wanted to
bring that up because it's a worry that
you know some of us have and
and you know we see it we see these
spiritual teachers buddhist teachers who
molest their students and steal and do
all kinds of
you know what seem like horrible things
they are horrible things from the
outside
and you gotta ask well what's going on
this person's been
meditating for 60 years and you meet
some of these people which i've gotten
the deep pleasure to meet
and they do seem highly transformed from
the inside
and as a sort of psychologist and
neuroscientist i look at these people
and i say
actually i do think that they're real in
the sense that they have transformed
their inner life
but the way the psychology works is
they've just bypassed
some of the stuff
and so there's still
inner trauma maybe from their childhood
or whatever that's in the biology that's
emerging as a behavior and they're just
have no conscious access to it they
actually don't have awareness you know
or they do and they have somehow tricked
themselves that it's okay because
they're helping people or whatever
right and so as a scientist that's super
fascinating that that can happen as a
person making a piece of technology to
try to help more people get there i also
need to be highly aware that that's a
possible outcome
yeah sorry that was a little bit of a
rant but yeah this is you know the thing
is
the point here is
some of this isn't free just waking up
knowing your true self uh seeing the
void having deep psychological insights
still doesn't make you a good person
that's a social thing and that still i
think has to be developed as a skill
compassion for example empathy
you know these things may come a little
bit for free but i think you also have
to just train your
your nervous system to get to those
things maybe even even being a good
parent i mean
maybe if you have a child and you wake
up so to speak
that may not necessarily make you
motivated to take care of your child you
know so you might need to have some
something else there to help that happen
yeah this is one point
for me and for many others what's
happened along the journeys is that
there are these vertical breakthroughs
in terms of realizations direct
experience of more and more of
infinite reality and then
what happens is immediately upon
realization what happens upon a vertical
integration of a higher density of
awareness love light let's say
that
then there's an immediate egoification
of said realization in a horizontal way
where the sense of self almost
immediately clicks back at a lesser
level but it clicks back and the only
word that so far that it really
encompasses the entirety of the
spiritual journey all the way to
self-realization and beyond
is purification
it's deconditioning it's
disentanglement it's unraveling or
deconstructing
um all separation every single last
little particle of separation of
conditioning and and that's the only way
to do it if you want to go all the way
otherwise like jay just said you're
going to get stuck at one of these
horizontal layers after a vertical
realization
and you you see this all the time you
see people's um
speaking enlightenment but speaking it
um
also quite clearly from a place
that has some sort of like visible
childhood conditioning that emerging
simultaneously um
so yeah so that's that's really really
really important from what james
mentioned there and certainly because it
makes it so that
um you have to you really have to ask
yourself if this is a full-time job
because that's what it is like the
synthesis of science and spirituality
and enlightenment and awakening and
service to others like you said earlier
that is a full-time job it just it's a
full-time job it comes your entire life
you incarnated potentially for this
exact reason
to come here to awaken and then serve
the creation awakening and so
um
this is really really a critical um
point of of the conversation
yeah and i just to pick on uh
or to springboard off of this notion of
purification
um
what's happening in the nervous system
in the body is that
there's multiple
levels fractals mandalas you know
however you want to think about this
it's even even visual perception which
is my background
is like an insanely complicated
hierarchy of processing but that
hierarchy is not just in the brain it's
the brain body connection and it's
actually the body to body connection and
it's the body as a people to history
connection and then and then if you go
inside the cell it's the dna to history
it's you know so this whole thing like
you're you're a vibration of vibrations
if you want to think about it like that
um and these vibrations are all entered
dynamically
acting in the brain and the body so let
me give you one example i was on a call
the other day with one of my scientific
heroes
his name is klemesh and he was he
actually showed that the peak beat so
the heartbeat if you take the peaks of
the heartbeat
let's say you know it's so many beats
per per minute
that predicts the alpha peak in the eeg
of the brain individually so right now
if i could record your heartbeat and i
could record your eeg brain electrical
activity i could look at your heartbeat
and it would be predicting something
very important about your brain activity
right so they're dynamically
nested all the way down your brain
activity is nested to your heart
fundamentally
and so
purification can happen i think at many
different levels
and that's again where this trap happens
because
i might think that i've cleared my
trauma you know from something that
happened in childhood
uh but that trauma may be stored in my
muscle
memory as much as it's stored in my
actual memory that i can consciously
access
but again what will happen is i'll do
all this trauma work and i'll purify it
and i'll clean it and i'll tell you i've
done it but it's still down in the heart
rhythm
all right there's another piece that was
physical because that trauma that
happened to me was a physical thing not
just a mental thing
and so purification also happens at
multiple levels and all this is changing
and again as a scientist that leads me
to think that this is just a lifetime
process
so even if you feel consciously that i
purified that trauma and you can talk
about it and have insights about it
it's probably not done and you got to
keep doing it and you probably got to do
some practice that
you got to do some weird body movement
practice or whatever right there's other
things that you're not even aware of yet
that are going to be needed
um to actually help the whole system
purify and then realign
um and again that's where you know i
think in the future we might have a
model of that like in 2100 or something
we'll have a model of what we mean by
purification which is so exciting to me
gosh you're so spot on we're we're
really riding on same
um
vibration there
because uh if you think about it
isn't to an extent
the
the model of evolution that we have of
the
formation of the self-referential
entities
um isn't there also the same thing
in terms of now we have a deacon a model
of deconstruction and purification of
said self-differential entity
to its primordial wonders
yeah so it's beautiful because you can
basically find a power law of the most
common conditionings
and then also a
a power law of the most
common ways to
decondition those conditionings so
um
like one of the most common ones is
unworthiness or um like seeking
validation
right
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna feel whole
by
uh acquiring followers or by um gaining
money or by
having women like me
um
that's like the most common one that we
fall into
and that if we if they're that that also
means there's a lip there's a pattern of
liberation
from those conditionings of the nest and
seeking validation
and there's nothing more liberating than
what i've had in direct experience with
liberation from those conditionings
and the more and more it becomes full
and complete and realized embodied in my
essence in my heart and in my gut
the more that i feel
like
i feel like a jedi or a ninja or i just
feel like i'm gliding through the field
rather than being at the the fixation
and attachments on on all those
different
points that would then
take you into a vortex and so that's
that's also very profound as um when you
think about those nested layers like you
said that there's this nested connection
it's almost like it's probably has a lot
to do with oxygenation like oxygenation
of the brain the heart
and then the oxygenation and that
enabling the
the connectomix to do its thing
so that rhythmic uh is so that's
fascinating and then
um
yeah it's it's probably also good for us
to
to play on
like if we were to pull up um
if we have any of these if you feel like
there's any insights from um some of
these things that we were looking at um
together before we started um i think
these would be quite helpful for people
um
so are we this is so you actually were
talking about this earlier but this here
is the is where you've identified as the
default mode sort of between the two
hemispheres to an extent
right yeah in this study here we're
using um ultrasound so this is a way to
basically get energy into the brain to
modulate it
and believe it or not you can use a high
frequency sound to
modulate the ion channels and perhaps
some other properties of the neurons
to
briefly safely modulate we're talking
about low energy ultrasound less around
the same range they use for fetal
imaging with ultrasound
so you can focus that beam of ultrasound
through the skull and that's what you're
seeing here is this red bit um is where
the ultrasound is focused
that's focusing on the anterior
cingulate which is a part of the brain
that helps you focus your attention and
we're interested in that for meditation
training
um but yeah that's this is kind of our
model so we're trying to model the
ultrasound to make sure it's safe you
know for where we're targeting for
people
do you feel like uh
the acc the anterior cingulate cortex do
you feel like so that area you would say
is heavily involved in attention
yeah it's involved in control of
attention and actually monitoring error
and this brings us back to the default
mode network so these of course all
these networks are interconnected in
some way
and what's going on with modern person
is we're bombarded by threat
fear you know the news and all this
stuff is tilted towards threatening you
to get you engaged and even facebook in
a sense is designed to kind of get you
riled up and you know
threat oriented they always seem to show
you the right people to like push your
buttons
and so the anterior cingulate cortex is
the part of the brain that's monitoring
for those threats and those errors and
whenever something comes at you and you
make an error
or a mismatch it sort of sends a signal
to another part of the brain to tell you
to pay attention
but in meditation it's probably also the
part of the brain that's noticing when
your attention wonders and it's telling
you oh bring your attention back
right and that bring your attention back
is a really crucial step in training for
mindfulness
that's part of the acc and so we think
that we can up regulate that a little
bit while you're learning to meditate
and that'll help you learn that skill a
little bit faster
now what's really cool about that is
that
if you meditate for like two years or
five years what tends to happen is that
that process becomes automatic and
implicit
and so
when you talk about the default state a
longer term meditator's default state is
to be monitoring
for their attention even if they're not
thinking consciously the brain just
starts doing it automatically
uh that happens to me like after a long
retreat you know you go for 10 days of
meditation and then at the end you're
just present
and you kind of know where your
attention is and what's grabbing it and
you can kind of feel your mind like oh i
want to go read about donald trump and
you're like ah look at that
like maybe i shouldn't do that just yet
i should just stay here
so yeah that's the acc it's a
fascinating part of the brain
wow so to an extent
the
acc um being the
um controlling of attention um
that to an extent we could say that this
like
bringing your attention back could be
spirituality has been called
abiding
so you're abiding as
this one infinite mystery rather than
abiding as the contracted form of self
that's seeking validation externally um
you're abiding in presence energy or in
consciousness or in god or
self-realization
um
cool
that word abiding it always after
retreats that's the word it's like
you're just abiding
that's beautiful that's pretty cool so
acc abiding it could be a
a pretty cool neuro if it's possible to
make a like a neuroscientific correlate
to spirituality like that that would be
really cool
nice
because even during the day
um
like bentino massaro has a really
popular aphorism it goes uh two to five
seconds
just relax all thoughts all
conceptualizations
all ideas all discursive thinking
and this also dates back to like zokchen
and mystic buddhism as well and it's
just literally just for those two to
five seconds
just
have a cessation of all of this uh
neuroscientific uh like cascades of the
triggers of thinking and concepts and
discursive thoughts and emotions etc and
what you do during that time is you
abide right so you think that's the
beauty of it is that if you
if you do this process
more and more often as it's called like
samadhi you kind of go into the state of
absorption of meditation
that if
it basically becomes 15 seconds then it
becomes minutes
and then before you know it you're just
sitting there in the middle of a [ __ ]
loud
room full of people or whatever
and you're in samadhi for like 20
minutes while you're just in a room full
of loud people and all you are is you're
the very field itself that's playing
with itself you're the whole thing
and
and you're no you're nowhere and
everywhere and it's indescribable and
that that
is
um
that like you said it's something that's
trained it's not something that's pilled
um the nervous system can't just pill
itself um into that not yet
um
but yeah but it's cool because you can
use entheogens along with
uh
practices like do nothing meditation or
vipassana or just basic mindfulness or
going on [ __ ] walks or all these very
basic things as well
and
as you do that self inquiry self inquiry
such a simple one logical as well
um
that
um that the combination of those things
will lead you to more and more of buying
so in a sense would you say would you
say that it's like a strengthening of
the acc
um in the beginning it is but then what
we find is that
as it becomes a from explicit or
conscious like you have to work at it to
implicit
then the acc goes back to baseline and
that's what's really cool
because
it's saying like something more than the
acc is changing and i i think again
what you just so beautifully described
gets back to this question of identity
and self you know at a certain point you
start asking what am i really
am i these thoughts am i this body am i
this worry you know what is what's
really going on and this gets into the
sort of metaphysics of buddhism which is
a fun topic
um but
you know you start getting insight into
what what's really here
and how does it work and
and you start watching the body make
these connections between emotion and
thoughts and
drives and behavior
but if you can just
rest
what shenzhen calls gone
which means just having a rest of
sensation and perception
and you can abide there for a minute
that's also conscious experience
and you can get to a point with to which
some people call non-dual consciousness
which is
there's a conscious awareness field that
has no content or
object or separation or anything and
it's just this field of nothing
a beautiful void of beautiful
nothingness
that's a possible experience that plenty
of people report on and it turns out
that the more that you get there through
whatever method
the more sort of relaxation and positive
vibes you get
it's you know it can cause you to have
sort of weirdness in the beginning but
as you stabilize that
um it's a bliss it's uh you know in the
jonic
practices jhana practices there's
pt the first level which is just this
overwhelming bliss and love and joy
and then you can keep going you can
stabilize that until you get to
nothingness
and at a certain point the system goes
is that me
am i also that or am i just the thoughts
and the body and the attachments and all
this stuff
and so you know again for me that's why
the d this gets to the deepest question
of what am i
who am i what am i identifying with why
am i identifying with that and is it
possible me for me to identify with not
that
and if i can identify with not that well
what does that mean
um you know and you're stepping through
and
and getting all this insight along the
way
so
yeah fun fun stuff
gosh that's so rich yeah that is
we're really at uh
we're really at one of the main
um
ways that the game is played um which
has been taught as a netty nettie uh not
this not that um you really have to
um have a fire under your ass to play
play the game but um if the fire under
the ass is bright enough and
uh has enough earnestness then you can
play
the netting eddie game shows up and when
it does
um it becomes something that you
perpetually do it's kind of interesting
so the acc increases and it's like
ability to maintain any netty or abide
and then over time then even that gets
transcended because it's not needed
anymore and then it becomes uh
like a it becomes like an ai like a that
runs in the background which is also a
buddha said it's a non-meditation
which is perfect
it's just a
again like a wakeful state um
yeah
cool
wow
somebody's asking about
depersonalization so this is um
an interesting experience that people
have you know in the clinic not just
with mindfulness and meditation
this is the experience that you're sort
of not in your body or somehow
separate in a way that's not functional
usually in the clinic so this is a
diagnosable issue for people
it can happen with certain drug induced
states as well but it also happens on
retreats meditation retreats and yoga
retreats
and
this is part of the sort of
dark side of these practices that as
your modulating self and as the self
maybe let's say you slip into the
samadhi for the first time and nobody
told you about it you weren't warned and
you just popped into it that can be very
scary actually it's not a fun experience
for people
and if you've already got some
underlying instability of the self
maybe due to past trauma or something
that's unresolved now you've got a
situation where the person
that the sense of self wants to protect
itself and so it just pops out and you
get this depersonalization derealization
problem
uh that's happened it's been reported on
retreats uh i have a good friend daniel
ingram
who's an er doctor and he would have
people show up
in a state like that at the er at the
hospital
and they get diagnosed as bipolar or
schizophrenic or something um but it
turns out that they're having what's
called a spiritual emergency
and uh daniel is working very hard to
actually get the medical establishment
to realize that these people can be
treated
not with
you know drugs that they treat something
like bipolar with but actually you just
do some inner practice and you pop back
into your body and now you know about
the void
or now you know about samadhi or
something we give you the framework so
you can understand what's happening to
you
so you know that's where
basically
knowing about these potential
alterations of consciousness can be
really helpful but if you don't warn
people of it then it can kind of spin
out into this other direction
unfortunately we're always changing and
so whatever happens to us now has to be
integrated into future self and
that's just the way the thing works you
know
and another thing is that
um
who is it that is worried about
depersonalization
you mean from a subjective point of view
yeah and of course for our our homie uh
john ferrer of course who posed the
question um but also in general um of
course there are
um what you could call crevices there
are these like crevices that you can
fall into um like you were describing
it's very very important um because if
there's not that stabilization like the
landing strip uh
community and and um
and optimal ways to to continue set
service to others instead awakening and
whatnot that then there can be issues
but um which we're we're sewing the
fabric well to to um
make their less to be less crevices
but
at the same time this is the exact thing
that people run away from
this is the number one thing people run
away from
is the question who are you
what are you
what is i
and
it's it's the question people run away
from because they don't want to
de-personalize they don't want to
trans-personalize
that's another way to think about it
it's trans-personalization
because we've become so accustomed to
singularly the individuated unit by
itself
and
i don't
it's really scary for someone to begin
being like well actually this is
the one talking to
itself
like atlas talking to jay is the one
talking to itself and
the field is what it is is what we are
we are that and you can't find it
anywhere because it's in its vibration
it's that emptiness dancing
and yet it's also everything it's every
single one of the atoms it's every
single one of
the words that are being vibrated across
the internet right now on being received
in that apparent location
and
so now you're really screwed because now
you went from a place of like spending
years decades even cultivating a sense
of self and cultivating a um
a
mentality that i am going to solidify my
sense of self
um and now when you're going through
more and more of the awakening
you're becoming more and more
deconstructing of that sense of self
that you were investing so much time
into it's depersonalizing it's
transpersonalizing
and
you can find that either liberating or
you can find it scary it's your will and
choice whichever way you see it um
but i promise you that if you take this
all the way it's kind of like biology or
art or any other field if you basically
stop at like researching a protein and
you never go all the way to the dna or
you never go all the way to like
bioengineering and eradicating
pathologies or whatever or an art if you
stop at paint and you never learn like
digital animation
or writing or poetry as well um that
what will happen is you'll note is that
you'll get stuck in yourself in that
specific thing and that you won't
actually notice all of the beautiful
potentiality that exists when you pick
up all of the field
when you pick that all up as yourself
because that's where true compassion
comes from as well is it when you're
when you're coming from a sense of self
compassion is for validation but when
you're coming from a place that's empty
of self when you're coming from a place
of the field compassion becomes more and
more incrementally
completely purely in service and so
that's the big shift as well you
actually you don't even know how you
behave right now into the field until
you empty yourself out more and more of
your personhood and its conditions and
separations and then you actually gain
sensitivity and subtlety with how you
put every word into the field
and that's a whole nother level of um of
awakening just saying oh i'm god
everything's god um that's you know
that's one layer um of it and then
there's more beyond that which is all
the subtlification the purification like
we were describing um
yeah during our conversation
so yeah love it yeah
yeah there's there's still a lot i mean
like i know that um we will rap um
that given we also spent like uh
like 45 minutes just preparing with
technical
technicalities and stuff so
um but next time what we'll do is um
we'll we already this is a good what we
did jay is we did a lot of sort of the
preparatory work after this two year so
we took two years uh
the first two gap was two years and we
this episode sort of did a good amount
of you could say like the
2000 end of 2021 like foundation so that
way if we revisit potentially we could
do one of these maybe like three times a
year or something like that and we could
we could revisit every four months or
whatever um we could revisit exactly
we can build on top of the foundation
like at the beginning of 2022 we can
start like building on top of the
foundation that we just laid down here
and
yeah
cool sure love to yeah we're working on
a model of
sort of neuro ethics that
shapes the way that we could have this
discussion but also shapes the way that
you create the tech
so that you
you can even ask the question am i
getting into that inner phenomenological
space that inner space of experience you
know how do i even make sure that that
thing is changing in the right way
the right way is an ethical question not
a scientific question but you know we're
trying to create a framework where we
can use science to test that ethical
framework so i think we've made a nice
foundation and sure next time we could i
could give you the model you know we
could look at that be pretty cool
cool yeah um actually neuroethics is
also a big one with um brain mind
michael mccullough the brain that's
right yep yep
yeah that's great
he's a good friend and yeah they're
working very hard they're going to have
an asilomar meeting where they come up
with some neuroethics guidelines and so
yeah i'm hoping to have something
prepared to sort of show at that at that
conference so it's awesome awesome
happening people are talking about it
and we're asking you know we're asking
the hard questions and you know we'll
we're going to get there we just uh got
to get through a couple rough patches as
a human species but and as an earth
system but you know we're working on it
everyone i think everyone at this point
needs to be working on it
and also as you do
see it as like this hard hardest
questions type thing also like just tune
in to the simplicity of the heart
at the same time thank you and yeah
yeah so
so we gotta balance that out because
it's cool finding the acc and and all
this unique
insights like
neuroscientific correlates to abiding or
whatnot very cool stuff
um yet at the same time it can really
boil down to like these profound like um
i believe roomie was one of them that
said this and maybe khalil gibran was
another but just quotes like between all
of the words that we speak so much love
is lost
yeah and yeah so you can really like
that's good
we could really boil this down as well
in in simple child-like heart-like ways
too very good yeah very good very good
um
cool jay is there other um important
thing that we need to wrap the
conversation with or do you feel like
we're intention fulfilled
um i think we're good i would leave your
your listeners with a concept that we
can bring up next time
it's called
epistemic appropriateness and
i think it gets to the heart of that
roomy quote actually i love that because
the question is what's the point of
quantifying the mind and measuring the
heart rate and
even measuring people who can get into a
john estate and the mri like what's the
real point there's a scientific point to
me which is understand mechanism and i'm
a geek i want mechanism but from a human
species point of view what's the point
um
and this there's this new phrase called
epistemic appropriateness which
basically says
is this
fitbit
is the information that i'm gleaning
from it appropriate for me to understand
myself
is it useful or not
and vr you're bringing up vr that's
another place where we start
understanding our experiences through a
representation instead of through our
eyeballs
and at a certain point you can get to
the point where you're understanding
yourself through vr
instead of understanding yourself
through your own body senses and that's
a really big philosophical uh oh like
we're getting into this weird territory
and so the idea um that i'm that's we're
sort of working on here is to say
all this information all this
quantifying all this showing you your
data
is important if and only if it's working
to the human fulfillment agenda
to the human agenda it's got to get back
to that inner what's happening with the
inner thing and how it knows itself
so anyway maybe we can start there on
the next one because that's the place
where i'm really trying to dig in
and uh and and really understand you
know how do you give the appropriate
amount of information to help you on
your own
personal journey
of understanding yourself and being
happy and having good relationships and
all the stuff i think we're trying to
get to
damn
nice yeah that's such a good way to rap
that's such a good um
epistemic appropriateness very
interesting yeah i i i
you know
i would you know suggest to people too
like as i'm thinking about this i'm
doing this in my own life i'm wearing
you know something that's tracking my
sleep
and the question is is it actually
making me have better sleep or not i
don't know
so yeah yeah
urge you to think about it
every single um
one of the most simple ones is this
it's the this is one of the most simple
ones bro
like
is it useful for you or not and and is
it helping you be useful for other
people that's the question
and actually everyone i feel like
everyone really knows deep in their
heart because everyone has this
experience when they finish scrolling
that they go
damn i just wasted so much time
[Music]
not not all the time not not everyone
all the time but a lot of people a lot
of the time have that experience which
is that's a big indicator
um so
wow
so so then that's a pretty like let's
look in um and investigate that because
there's we're talking about neurotech
and human flourishing but the thing that
billions of people have around the
planet right now that is
tech that directly influences neurology
is
so
saliently distracting us from
potential actualizations
um that are uh going latent or dormant
because of the
styles of programming and design that
we've implanted with them so there's a
lot of these that just with epistemic
appropriateness very cool
yeah
very cool
awesome
um beautiful and also there's a links in
the bio below as well um let me actually
let me pull them up here on our
second screen
so the first
link down in the bio
is the
sema lab
so that's sema lab.arizona.edu
sonication enhanced mindfulness mindful
awareness
and
you can find more information here
about the team
about research
about some of the news
oh there's some good content on here one
of them is
a recent guardian video um that was
published on the work that's a really
strong short video highly recommend
checking this out also jay giving us
tedx talk
great interview
guru viking and also uh
jayce talk at brain mind
so
oh yeah and then there's also so check
this link out in the bio and then
there's also um the center for
consciousness
um
and
this is also a university of arizona um
center for consciousness studies and
here this is um there's
this is um
uh roger penrose and uh stuart hamroff
right they're both
uh
deeply
um intertwined here yes
yep yeah roger penrose won the nobel
prize last year so we uh dedicated a
small short conference to him this year
so it was all on black hole theory and
consciousness quantum consciousness you
know these concepts
and uh it's all free on youtube so i'd
recommend watching there's some awesome
awesome
lectures and content on black holes and
consciousness and
you know
sort of the edge of science in a sense
yep there they are
um
oh nice these just went up a week ago
yep uh the conference was earlier in
august
uh we just got all the content up so
good stuff
nice
very cool
um
so
very very cool
um
so guys check
this out as well so again that's the
center for conscious studies and you can
all find the link to the youtube channel
here as well
and
um
yeah and then also you can find jay's
website as well so you have jay's
weddite as well
um link down there you can go and follow
him linkedin twitter
um you can also go follow shinzen young
as well
um
and
awesome so let's uh let's wrap
i'll get you
get you going
um
nice yeah cool i'm glad uh i'm glad we
had some love in the comments thanks fam
we love you so much thanks for tuning in
yeah thanks for tuning in guys um we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below also so write us your
thought in the comments we would love to
hear from you about the episode about
what jay was sharing with us
also um if you haven't yet subscribe to
the channel also like the video as well
that helps algorithm share the video
with other people that you feel like
this would profoundly influence on the
synthesis of signs of spirituality and
neurotech to maximize human flourishing
and
support jay at the links below in the
bio
and that is all folks um jay i'm going
to end the stream but stay in the studio
for another minute with me okay all
right well thanks this is was a
beautiful conversation great questions
and yeah let's i would do this every
week if there was time so let's do it
again sometime soon i love you so much
bro we're on the exact same sign
spirituality
actually shinzon young i believe was the
one that said that quote about it's the
only trillion dollar idea is the
synthesis of science spirituality that's
right so good
we're on it ronnie you'll see us back
again soon fam
yeah thank you very much
thanks jay